hey everyone thanks for tuning in to
another episode of ranking before we get
into our show
i want to give a big shout out to our
sponsor grammar as ceo of jubilee media
have to do a lot of writing
and grammarly is an amazing digital
writing assistant
the grammarly browser extension is super
simple to download just go to
grammarly.com
and click install now that's it the free
version of grammarly has basic grammar
and spelling suggestions but upgrading
to premium is totally worth it
and here's why grammarly helps make
vocabulary suggestions to make your
writing
more exciting and effective it also
makes clarity suggestions so you can
make your writing more concise
finally grammarly helps you with the
tone of your writing
and provides a little feedback on
whether or not your wedding sounds
professional
go to grammarly.com jubilee to sign up
for a free account and get 20
off grammarly premium today again that's
grammarly.com
now enjoy the episode
[Music]
i wasn't planning to go to college that
wasn't like a goal of mine my parents
were like well you should apply to at
least one college and i was like
i'll never get in here and then i went
to yale
[Music]
should we just like go down and do
intros yeah i'm chad
i'm 24 i work in finance i have a
bachelor's degree i
went to yale i'm tyler i'm 21 i'm a high
school graduate and i work in the marine
corps
i'm kaylie i'm 25 i'm a software
developer i went to ohio university
and i have a bachelor's degree maria i'm
30 years old
i have my phd in cancer biology and i
work in a biotech industry
grad school i went to university of
south carolina in undergrad i went to
university of florida
hi everybody my name is shawn i'm 27
i'm the director of social media for a
company and i also work for
ad agency i got a double major in dance
and cultural anthropology
underground i went to loyola marymount
university hi everybody i'm ray i'm 24.
i graduated with a bachelor's degree in
harvard recently and i work in
consulting
all younger babies i know this thing is
age
factor yeah it gives you like years of
experience like this
um we need a maybe it's good to identify
what intelligence means everybody
i think intelligence is better defined
as your adaptability
and your problem-solving skills more
than it is your education obviously like
the education the stuff you've been
through puts a lot into playing it
because it gives you more resources more
thoughts to draw from the formal
education definitely helps but
i don't think it's in any way essential
so what is the most essential
so the most essential thing was probably
common sense yeah so for me personally i
think
intelligence is both eq iq and that
common sense
street smart intelligence all of that
combined people
consciously or unconsciously when they
see someone form an opinion
immediately like i'm sure we all did
right away when i saw you
i told myself maria do not judge him
just by his looks
he could be throwing you off or that's
just who he is
but he can talk to talk and walk the
walk
sean i didn't want to judge him based on
the way he looks or dresses or acts so i
was like i think he's intelligent
first impressions i would put him at the
bottom only because when i was in school
all the other people with like the
bright neon colors and stuff they were
typically the ones doing worse in
classes
if we were ranking confidence i'd
definitely put sean at
very first place so what is the
definition that we're going with
is the biggest question i like your
definition i just say i like my
definition
it combines everything does anyone have
any like initial
you can be honest start on that side i'm
done going
i feel like i have a good combination of
both like book smart and street smart
so yeah i think i have some input on
that there's so many
aspects to intelligence it really goes
beyond iq
and eq even those two different factors
really don't really
capture what it really means to be
intelligent i know i'm not you know
from yale i don't have a phd but what i
lack in those areas i'm able to still
problem solve and use my own skill set
my emotional intelligence as well as my
social intelligence besides my
education and background i feel like i
have high like emotional intelligence
like i'm aware of my surroundings
as a software developer my problem
solving skills are obviously
top notch i think i would say my whole
life i've kind of had to
fight to be seen as intelligent i think
i'm so used to having to do that as a
woman to just like step up and be like
i deserve to be here my first job out of
college i was working at a law firm
gentlemen came up to me and said hi um
you don't look like
somebody that would work at a law firm
you look like somebody i'd go on spring
break with
and i'm like obviously out of everyone
here
i've got the least formal education i
consider myself intelligent my mental
dedication
and my ability to adapt and to
problem-solve what i do in the marine
corps i'm a
seber defense specialist so i think that
by virtue of what i do that already
requires
some amount of intelligence sorry quick
question so
do you think that only certain people
can do your job or do you think
anyone can do your job only certain
people you have to take the asvab before
you go into the military that's uh
not really how much you know but how
well you can learn information and i got
94 on that
it's not an amount of how much you study
how much you know you're not going to
really
get better at learning does that make
sense i
strongly disagree with you don't get
better at learning the idea that you can
get better at learning is a pretty big
signifier of intelligence
i'm very much dyslexic i have adhd
and i'm on the autism spectrum dyslexia
means that there's a big gap in
comprehension
so i was scoring 99th percentile in
certain areas and like
third percentile and others i'll never
be able to learn another language
i took spanish for 12 years and i can
still basically only order a burrito so
i have a question
why did you go to yale and why did you
go to harvard my parents are immigrants
from china
i'm a first generation immigrant as well
and
college student as well my family always
really stressed the importance of
formal education for me that was
something that i really strived for
i wasn't planning to go to college i
didn't it wasn't like a goal of mine
my parents like well you should apply to
at least one college and i was like
i'll never get in here and then i went
to yale
why don't you guys rank each other from
one to six including yourself
and give reasons why you want to do what
you're doing gotta go one
no oh yeah two three
four five six i would
rank you as a six not meaning that
you're not intelligent
i also think that i don't place a lot of
value on the military
[Music]
period no that yeah
i'd probably do one two
three four
five six i'm sorry i'm the bill in this
episode
does anyone think they're like either
end of the spectrum i'd say i'm one if
nothing else because
i know what i'm about and i'm sure that
wait you guys have to rank everyone too
that is so unfair
no no no no i would say
one two three four five six
okay i think one
two three four
five six sorry oh sorry it's
hard for me to look past the education
part going to college i think you learn
a lot if nothing else emotionally
i still think you're smart one
two three four five
six one immigrant parents
first generation going to college humble
modest
two me i don't know phd cancer biology
scientists i work in a biotech company
we make copic 19 testing kits
stuff like that and then six it has
nothing to do with your background
i don't think you really have the
highest eq out of all of us
tyler he ranked last for me personally
because the way he carries himself he
was
ranking intelligence based on his point
of view and not taking in other people's
point of views and
compiling results but really just came
down to his body language his demeanor
the way he carried himself the way he
acted towards the group
i would put one
two three
four five and out of six so the reason
why i put
you at number one is i think you have
the highest not only
eq score out of everybody but the way
you present yourself as well as being a
phd student i think is just like
a huge thing when i put myself six
because i feel like i might be the
weakest in terms of actual iq score
hopefully i can make it up and
everything else
so i did put myself as least intelligent
however if it can't be
me i definitely think tyler
unfortunately
his way of thinking is linear
and i think intelligence is almost like
a sphere it's a picture
and right now he's only coloring with
one color then you know with the rainbow
so who got the most number one
i feel like you were definitely three
right yeah i mean between forever
sure i think that i sort of expected to
be ranked a little bit lower
at first glance and first interaction
with me
it's hard to tell how intelligent i am
it's hard to tell how intelligent
anybody is
is anyone upset with where they're
standing i think it makes sense that i'm
down here like the guy graduated from
high school and then joined the military
he probably wouldn't be
like high up on there if i was in their
shoes i definitely would have also
ranked myself among the lowest
i do feel like there might be a
prejudice acting in terms of ranking
you okay i was thinking highly but i
agree with the ranking i think you
probably are the most intelligent out of
all of us
i would feel weird placing you there and
not acknowledging
the dynamics in which we did so
[Music]
hearing that to take an iq test was
definitely hard to hear
quantifying things for me in that realm
is really hard because it gives you
something really
solid even if you don't buy into iq
tests it still gives you a number at the
end of the day
which is something you have to grapple
with
i literally thought when you said to
open the computer we're going to look at
social media
i didn't think an iq test would be part
of it
[Music]
it was kind of expected we're being
ranked by intelligence you know an iq
test it's not that far off the wrong
possibility
so number one is raymond number two
would be kelly
number three will be tyler and number
four would be
shayda number five is sean and number
six is maria
i think an iq test tests something i
don't think it's intelligence it's
definitely testing something
iq tests are now known to be flawed and
like based on incorrect
sample sizes i have really severe
dyslexia there's two questions on that
test that i automatically basically
can't answer
i'm sure if you studied for an iq test
you would do a lot better
iq tests are just one aspect or one way
to measure
intelligence it's really on a spectrum
what constitutes somebody as intelligent
before this all i knew about iq tests is
that they existed
and the i stands for intelligence i've
never looked into iq tests before coming
here today
i'm saying the eq that was the first
time i've ever heard that term in my
life
coming back to intelligence it's not
just your iq it's your eq
it's your common sense it's street
smarts sure it is
some type of metric similar to an sat
and a ct score is a metric for getting
into college but there's more to that
person
than that test i'm actually excited i
wasn't last because i thought i was
gonna be last not gonna lie
i think an iq test is a good indicator
to see how people
handle pressure but i think that's
easier to make sense in our heads that
oh you're smart
and you're not smart definitely don't
think it's the best metric i've been
exposed to tests like these
probably more than most people here that
already gives me an unfair advantage
this is my villain redemption arc and
climbing up the ladder